A more recent feature added to the FBIK node within Control Rig is something called sub-chains.
Now, sub-chains are essentially a way to limit the effect an effector has on the whole body,
and you can do this by defining a small chain of bones within it.
So for example, you could create a sub-chain from the hand to the shoulder, which will
essentially leave the rest of the body unaffected until this sub-chain of the hand has reached
its limit, and then it will engage the rest of the body to pull towards the effector.
So let's take a look at a use case for that with our character.
Now I'd like to show this off in a more exaggerated way.
So what I've done is I've disconnected our existing logic here with the existing full
body IK node, and I've created a new one with a much more simple setup.
So we have our right hand in here, and we don't have any bone settings, we're not excluding
any bones.
The only thing I'm going to change is the root behavior and set that to Pinter Input
just to show this off more clearly.
So when I grab this right hand here, you can see that the whole body from the pelvis to
the wrist is reacting to me pulling this effector around.
Now when I pull the effector closer to the body, you wouldn't naturally lean that way.
The same as when I lift the effector up or when I lift the wrist up.
You wouldn't expect the body to be reacting like this.
And so this is what sub chains can help you correct.
So in our chain depth option here, this allows us to count how many bones up the chain we
would like the sub chain to be.
So in our case, a value of two would give us our lower arm and then our up arm.
And the other thing that we need to change to activate sub chains would be the sub iterations
here inside the settings dropdown.
And if we set that somewhere between five and 10, that should give us some pretty decent
results.
So if I select the effector or the hand control here, you'll see that we can now move it towards
the body.
And although it does react a small amount, which is quite nice, it's no longer leaning
all the way over.
And we can also lift it up and move it around within its limitations without affecting the
rest of the body.
And as soon as we exceed those limitations, you can see that we do engage the rest of
the body.
And they can be a quite simple setup.
And if we increase this to three, for example, we'll just go slightly higher up the chain
to engage the collarbone.
And you probably want to set some sort of bone settings limits for this eventually,
but you can see that as we've added one more bone to the chain depth, it's increased or
it's changed which bones we're affecting.
And this can really help you get some more natural poses out of your character and fix
any sort of awkwardness that you're getting with the whole body moving when you think
it shouldn't be when you're lifting a hand, for example.